the cloud architecture quest provides  hands-on lab practice on topics related  to the associate cloud engineer a  certification exam click enroll in this  quest to get started  beginning with the cloud iam QuickStart  lab complete all labs in this quest make  sure to review related product  documentation that is linked from the  lab instructions the quick labs catalog  has hundreds of self-paced labs on  various topics it is highly recommended  that you complete the labs in the GCP  essentials quest and more to get  additional hands-on practice remember  the more you practice the more  proficient you will be in the topics  related to the associate cloud engineer  certification exam  when you complete quick labs quests you  will receive quick labs badges that you  can showcase on your LinkedIn or social  media profile to highlight your  accomplishments to potential employers